[Musique]
g
t
nicolas blanc bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv façon visite
pause ne se vit pas vous êtes producteur
de films à succès apparemment
du moins pour l'instant et vous êtes
yvelinois bien sûr ce qui permet de nous
inviter alors vous avez une actualité
qui est toute chaude
c'est un film qui vient de sortir
mercredi fin il ya quelques jours
produit absolument oui mercredi mais bon
4 mercredi
papa mais tout frais et ce film
s'appelle gaspard va au mariage monde
cependant elle encore dit que vous avez
produit avec votre société qui s'appelle
agat films et compagnie et compagnie
voilà voilà je vous propose partons de
regarder déjà la bande annonce qu'on
voit de quoi il retourne
seulement voilà je vous proposais
quelque chose je vous venez avec moi
chez mon père
la compagnie vous restez un peu vous
repartirez plus tard
qu'est ce que je vais faire chez votre
père elle se marie aïe il se remarie
il faudra quelqu'un avec moi
[Musique]
je veux embrasser la mariée voilà c'est
l'aura bien car ebooks et bien-être et
la deux têtes
je le vois ok
paris
avec elle depuis longtemps passé se rend
compte de la chance que tu as une combi
grandir dans un zoo
cora coline mattel bonjour mon fils je
me demandais si j'étais pouvoir un jour
je suis là d'accord je vais dormir à
côté du nid à l'ours ne rentrent pas du
tout qui fait dormir avec moi sauf si
toi tu as peut-être peur que cette façon
crue et ça me fera pas inquiète pas
[Musique]
le mariage c'est peguy plus marié une
semaine de la noce va nous coûter un max
de fric ça
patmar y être
si affaires papa je sais pas c'était une
zone
elle sait ne pas créer déguisé en fille
jalouse sk attente il s'est fait pour le
sol est saturé cache ta ville
mettez-vous toi moi je suis à
tous les jours des scoops et compter les
uns sur les autres dans cette famille
paris dont nous sommes toujours le désir
d'enfant qui cherche être aimé de sa
famille
le plus difficile c'est de trouver
quelque part de quelqu'un qui n'aime
plus que sa famille
[Musique]
donc voila c'était gaspard à au mariage
enfin la bande annonce un film d'antony
cordier avec josh christa théret
guillaume gouix johan heldenbergh et
marina foïs
voilà un film mac pour l'instant marche
très très bien il ya des critiques
dithyrambiques
bah c'est un film qui est étonnant parce
que c'est une comédie c'est une
fantaisie sur une famille
dysfonctionnelle mais comme toutes les
femmes ils mettront je pense plutôt
atypique et très atypique vivons dans un
zoo et donc le montage du film a été
assez compliqué et l'accueil du film par
la presse d'abord et par le public pour
l'instant est magnifique de oui on est
très content parce que c'est du combat
qu'on mène pendant longtemps pour que le
film existe
et quand ils existent et que il est bien
reçue passer ses débuts - un peu magique
court après on replonge dans la balade
dure vie de producteur mais là diouf
producteurs avaient mis le doigt sur ce
dont je voulais parler à côté moi votre
société elle existe depuis quand la
chasse à l'homme est lancée dans la
profession moi je me suis lancé dans la
profession fait c'est j'ai fait là gros
d'abord en fait doucher un parcours
particulier j'ai fait là gros et puis à
la suite de ça m'intéressait pas
beaucoup je me suis dit il faut que je
change gamin j'adorais le cinéma mais
j'étais dans une famille où cinéma
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui était
très lointain et papa d'accès pas
accessible et c est donc j'ai commencé à
bosser un peu juste mais de façon je
peux pas faire toute ma vie là dedans
et donc j'ai commencé à prendre des
cours de théâtre voir à peu est ce que
je pouvais faire et donc au bout de deux
heures mais j'ai tout lâché ggg comment
c'est fait j'ai fait un an d'école
d'acteurs disque ou pas ça qui
m'intéressait est ce si beau je rentrais
dans la fabrication des films mais je ne
savais rien de rien donc je suis rentré
d'une première boîte je fais des stages
mais comme beaucoup de gens en fait un
je ne sais rien de cette voie là et puis
sur un tas d'or une première boîte de
production puis j'ai créé une boîte de
production pendant deux ans et là je
suis rentré dans un collectif de
producteurs qui s'appelle agat films qui
était déjà une structure organisée avec
plusieurs producteurs et
et ça existe c'est toujours là où je
suis depuis maintenant je rentre en 92
dont il ya quand même quelques années
les années vous êtes à une trentaine de
films d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression qu'on
produise ce que je vous disais je n'ai
pas compté des films jeu j'aurais du mal
un peu a résumé ce que c'est que même ma
vie de producteur je pense que moi je
n'ai toujours exercée sur les coups de
coeur c'est dire que je suis arrivé dans
ce métier parce que j'en avais envie
sans avoir vraiment préparé et je
l'exercé toujours sur des coups de coeur
dont j'ai d'abord ce n'est pas dans les
colonies est-ce qu'il ya une question
les caractéristiques qu'on retrouve dans
chacun d'eux film que vous avez produit
est ce qu'il y à un angle une un goût
particulier je pense qu'amat gros de
grosses machines de guerre commerciale
déjà non grossmann à un hiver commercial
non je pense que ceux qui
j'ai jamais voulu en tout cas me définir
une ligne éditoriale ce n'est pas le
sens pour moi encore une fois je
fonctionne un peu au coup par coup le
dernier film que j'ai produit c'est un
film qui s'appelle le jeune karl marx
oui qui était une grosse machine à la
historiques politiques avant la mer
univers avec mathilde seigner donc j'ai
fait des essais fait pas mal de comédie
j'aime beaucoup la comédie c'en est une
bd un peu barrés comme ça avec des
personnages moi j'ai besoin d'être
touchés en fait parler parler d'accord
aujourd'hui vous parler du film d'auteur
par exemple oui oui absolument faut
absolument finale corse qui est sans
doute voilà pas forcément le plus
facilement faire en france on a quand
même beaucoup de facilités pour produire
des films d'auteur oui d'accord bombe a
coûté tant mieux dites moi dans ses
interviews antony cordier donc le
réalisateur de gaza avant mariage dit il
a déjà fait de réaliser deux premiers
films celui ci dans quel troisième et il
dit qu'il ya alors j'ai pas trop compris
c'est entre cinq ou sept ans l'espace
entre le deuxième est celui ci il dit
que c'était très compliqué au niveau des
producteurs etc
qu'est ce qui fait que ce soit si long
que quand ça s'est passé pour ce film
via tout bas je pensais que j'en suis
depuis le début canon absolument
parental interne et il a produit ses
deux premiers films avec avec une
société production qui s'appelle why not
il a produit le premier qui s'appelle
touche froide le deuxième s'appelle
la piqûre happy few et puis voilà la
relation à garder ma voix là et il est
venu vers moi c'était en 2013 cet
écrémage
je l'avais appelé pour un film pour lui
proposer un film et il a bien verrait
déjà
oui j'ai bien dit avec lui quand il
n'était pas libre puisqu'il était en
train d'écrire ça et donc il m'a appelé
mon écoute est ce que tu te souviens
nenê 1 est ce que tu voudrais dire mon
scénario donc j'ai lu j'ai trouvé ça
absolument formidable et très facile et
on est partis là-dessus d'accord et sa
années 50
et ça a mis du temps parce qu'il ya
toujours une année de très près c'est un
mois je trouve ces âmes un peu long
alors que selon un principe en trois ans
on arrive entre boucler le scénario
après la recherche de financements et
puis après y'a quand même entre la
fabrication de celui dont la tournée il
ya un an et demi presque
mais là quand le tour de 10 mois
qu'elles sont comment dire votre travail
et vous alors c'est d'aller chercher des
financements montrant là moi c'est
d'aboutir une proposition artistique
avec le réalisateur sur la corde et par
le premier interrupteur c'est le
réalisateur qui vient avec un scénario
qu'il l'ait écrit soit il ya un bouquin
qu'il veut adapter et donc à partir de
ça on va on va définir le pejak
travaillent ensemble voilà il ya des
choses que vous faites changé par
exemple ah bah oui on parle parle
beaucoup
ouais oui oui on va on parle de tout moi
je dis là je me lave honnêtement on
s'emmerde
on a ferait remonter ça ou vous êtes le
premier spectateur
voilà un chat qui n'existait pas encore
exactement une fois qu'on a défini donc
j'ai vraiment votre vision finalement
c'est avec celui du réalisateur bien
celui du réalisateur pour moi
j'accompagne celui de réalisateur je
pense que le
l'artiste et le réalisateur ciel moi je
l'accuse analysé je vois là je suis
celui qui l'attend à 10 pouces qui dit
attention là tout laisse un peu aller
honnêtement ça va plus mais il est
laïque s'arrêter de si on regarde les
différents sujets produits sont assez
différents les uns des autres sur 13
juin parce que je vais accompagner quand
j'accompagne raoul peck dans dans le
jeune quart marc réalisateur haïtien
voilà ça n'a rien à voir régulation dont
voilà le boulot il est passionnant de ça
d'ailleurs d'accord et alors du coup je
me suis vu mes questions donc voila
quand on accompagne donc voilà on a ce
package et puis à ce moment là je vais
chercher de l'argent
effectivement pendant ce temps on va
chercher des acteurs oci donc ça c'est
encore mieux
oui enfin l'argent très je devais tout
cela j'ai mis tout seul je vais pas tout
le casting oui on fait ça en commun etc
avec toujours le réalisateur qui pour
moi à la le dernier mot si la syrie
travailler avec un acteur il n'est pas
question d'aller bien pressé voilà après
vrai on échange ça puis après on met
lass est là mais fabrication préparation
tournage montage dire tout ce qu'on a
tourné on en fait un film
et puis après c'est tout temps de
l'exploitation pour arriver le 31
janvier dans ce cas là à sortir le film
mais avec juste avant la presse voit la
prévention et la promotion est devenue
sa est forcément l'on prend un minimum
de 3 ans d'aventurés et donc là vous
êtes en vous travaillez sur un prochain
film
donc là je travaille sur deux prochains
films en fait qu'ils sont voilà qui sont
en stade a avancé un premier qui vont se
tourner en mai juin un film avec
catherine frot et daniel auteuil qui
s'appelle tu exagères qui est une
comédie aussi un peu barrés sur 2 200 le
jeune retraité nom qui va se tourner en
mai chantal voilà et puis un autre film
de l'équipe avec qui il avait fait un
film qui s'appelle la c zéro sur des
jeunes de banlieues qui avait quitté un
prime voilà que j'aime beaucoup aussi et
on tourne à 1
une histoire autour d'un personnage qui
est un jeune rappeur ultra qu'on nous
appelle mhd je sais pas si vous
connaissez des va être l'acteur
principal d'un film comme ça qu'on va
tourner entre paris le nord est des
stars les contournent aussi au même
moment d'ailleurs encore écouter c'est
passionnant bah oui on s'ennuie par une
personne n'eut pas et puis donc mais ce
film remporte plein de succès
actuellement au cinéma dans le film où
il marche très bien souvent à l'étranger
etc
oui il ya un petit truc qui se passe qui
fait qu' on sent que le l'accueil est
très bon que les gens acceptent cette
fantaisie qui est dit effectivement
détonne un peu dans le land cinéma
français est bien celui là bas pour moi
oui je suis sûr ça fait du bien on est
d'accord
ah oui c'est que l'hiver s'est réuni
vers c'est archi touchant c'est émouvant
c'est vraiment la façon dont ce chacun
doit quitter un moment le monde de
l'enfance un monde de l'enfance qui là
est très heureux parce qu'il vivait dans
un zoo ils sont heureux mais il ya des
drames comme dans toute vie et à un
moment il faut s'extraire de sa est allé
dimension toute particulière pour young
qui joue le père un acteur belge qui est
juste fantastique très bel homme qui
très bel homme même dans un aquarium
avec des poissons
voilà il n'hésite pas à wilson acteur
absolument magnifique ça c'était
vraiment une idée d'anthony j'avais
jamais j'aurais jamais pensé à ça et les
magnifiques les magnifiques scènes et
décors le décor est sublime aussi
et bah écoutez bravo merci bah merci me
produisais nous plein d'autres films de
cet acabit
quand on va se régaler sur merci nicolas
bientôt à novara
[Musique]